ago let's bring in the former dhs acting
secretary chadwolf mr secretary i want
to get your reaction to what the press
secretary there had to say
about the issues when it goes to border
patrol how the administration's
relationship with border patrol agents
what that relationship looks like uh the
press secretary jensac is saying that
the role that border patrol agents play
is of great value for the administration
and will refer you to dhs for further
comment
well i think it's fascinating she
absolutely had nothing to say about the
video that has been uh seen by millions
of folks right now that is underscoring
the challenges that the border patrol
has on the border these days and it's
it's just remarkable video because
they're asking some very difficult
questions about how do they solve this
crisis that's been going on for 12
months and whether it was the chief of
the border patrol or certainly secretary
marcus who sat there
in that video and didn't say much they
have no answer
the secretary continues to come out on
twitter and elsewhere saying that he's
going to give the resources to the
border patrol for them to do their job
the border patrol has been very clear
they want the policies to change they
want this crisis to change so that they
can get the border under control and
time and time again the policies don't
change and the crisis continues and we
continue to have a historic security
crisis and humanitarian crisis on that
border so uh where you know where we're
going where the border patrol sees the
lack of leadership from the department
is something that we have never seen
before yeah a significant in-person
challenge and significant that it was
videoed and released to the media and
let's just get to that video real quick
uh what we've been talking about
been doing here job as long as y'all
that's the problem
that's the problem chief
for people the triumph is for good men
to do nothing i can't hear you for evil
the triumph is for good men to do
nothing that's exactly what's happening
here good men are doing nothing you're
allowing the league
you are doing something
now this is dhs leadership under the
bide administration facing border patrol
agents when you see that video and that
dynamic there how much of this has to do
with administration policies or just the
laws on the books that say you can show
up at a port of entry and claim asylum
and that's what we're seeing here
well my heart breaks for those border
patrol agents look at the end of the day
this is about policy and i think what
you had the border patrol agent there in
the video talking about is you're not
changing policy so that we can do our
job you know we we demonstrated under
the trump administration you can give
them the tools the resources and the
right policies for them to secure that
border and for them to do their job
we're not seeing that today and again in
that video you had secretary my orcis
not say a word
sit there if you're the secretary you
step up and you say look i'm i'm here
talk to me talk about the policies and
i'll give you direct answers and we
didn't see that and that's what the
border patrol is looking for is
leadership first and foremost
former dhs secretary chad wolfe chad
thanks so much for joining us